[music]
Hi everyone.
So, it was a summer day in 2016.
There's a guy in shiny leather jacket
and big biceps hurling a large metal
tray into an office. And on that piece
of metal, he wrote, "To Elon and the
OpenAI team, to the future of computing
and humanity, I present to you the first
DJX1."
And that was the first time I met
Jensen. And as any good interns would
do, I rush in line and I signed my name
on it. But back then, I had no idea what
I signed up for. And for the next 10
years, no one summarized it better on
what happened than Ilia himself. If you
believe in deep learning, deep learning
will believe in you. And oh boy, did
deep learning believe in us big time.
Three-step functions, six years. That's
all it took to get us here. And the
first tick is GPD3 pre-training. Next
word prediction is learning the rules of
grammar, the shape of language, right?
It's learning to simulate how strings
and code should unfold.
And then 2022 instruct GPT. It aligns
the simulation to do useful work and 01
reinforcement learning learns to surpass
imitation learning. And finally, we get
to the agentic era where auto research
accelerates the whole loop beyond what's
humanly possible.
And as Andre said, the LMS and the
frontier labs are getting to the final
boss fight. So LMS are right in the
thick of the end game. And honestly, I'm
so jealous, right? The LM folks, they
are throwing the parties of their
lifetime. They're having such a great
time speedrunning AGI on the backs of
mythical beings literally called mythos.
But what do roboticists have? We should
also have some of that fun. So as any
self-respecting scientist will do, I
copy homework and we give it a new name,
the great parallel. So instead of
simulating the next word, we simulate
next world state. And it will align that
world model onto the robot by action
fine-tuning. And finally, we do
reinforcement learning on top to surpass
what's possible.
So that brings us to the next episode,
robotics, the endgame. And sorry, I just
couldn't resist.
So how do we play the endg game? It all
boils down to two things, the data
strategy and the model strategy. And
looks at the model first.
So the past three years robotics was
dominated by VAS and models that grew to
1.7 U pi and RT2 are all in this
category. But really if we think about
it the VAS should be LVAS
because most of the parameters are
dedicated to language. So language is
first class citizen followed by vision
and action. But if you think about it,
it's not quite right. Right. It's head
heavy in the wrong places because VAS
are better at nouns and understanding
knowledge instead of verbs and
understanding physics. So we need a
second pre-training paradigm and I
thought it would be glorious but
unfortunately we call it AI video slop
you know I can look at leone fat all day
right it's peak internet but it's very
hard for anyone to take this seriously
until we realize that the video models
are learning to simulate next physical
state so these are generated by Nvidia
Cosmos 3 and you can see that the model
learns the concepts of buoyancy,
gravity, reflection, collisions, all by
predicting the next blob of video
pixels. Everything here is an emergent
property and the models can even do
visual planning. So on the left,
starting from an initial frame, you can
run the simulation forward in time in
pixel space and Cosmos is able to solve
this maze. But also sometimes it makes
mistakes. So here's my favorite.
Watch very closely
and if you blink, you missed it. You can
see that when you're not looking, these
video models see geometry as optional.
And I call this physics slop. So the
models are still not perfect, but
they're getting there.
Now, how do we make these world
simulators useful? We do that by
grounding it into robot actions by
collapsing that entanglement of all
future states into a slice that matters
on the robot.
So it's a new type of policy model that
we're introducing on the upper right
corner. This is not real camera feed.
What you're seeing is the robot
dreaming. It's predicting what to do
next by generating videos a few seconds
into the future. And here we can disturb
the scene and the policy is robust to
that because it can replan on the fly.
So how it works is we take a pre-trained
video diffusion model and we let it
jointly decode the actions and the
videos into the future. And this is very
different from VAS which takes a frame
and predicts the action directly. So
it's kind of doing a visual chain of
salt in the pixel space. And you can see
the robot here assembling this toy
airplane by using tools and do so end to
end fully autonomous.
And here's another example. We have the
robot setting up a circuit in a novel
configuration.
So it's kind of a GPD2 moment for us,
right? It's not perfect, but it's almost
therapeutic to see the robot assembling
these circuits for hours on end
programmed by just a few demonstrations.
And we call this new category world
action models or that will be the next
generation of group.
And next, let's talk about data
strategies.
So here is Beldali, Nvidia's chief
scientist, Kelly operating a humanoid
robot at our lab. And given his salary,
this is probably the most expensive
training data we have ever collected in
our training set.
So over the past three years from 2022
to 2025, it was a golden era of teleop.
There was VR and hyper optimized
streaming. Um, and there are also these
complex risks that look like medieval
torture devices. A lot of investment
made by the industry. A lot of pain and
suffering going into teleyop.
But what's worse, teleyop is
fundamentally upper bounded by 24 hours
per robot per day. And actually, who am
I kidding? It's more like three hours
per robot per day because the robots
throw a tantrum all the time and you
have to babysit them. So, can we do
better?
Any one of you here driving Tesla? You
know that when you're driving Tesla,
you're actually uploading data as you
drive. And the beautiful thing is you
don't even feel it because a data upload
process is ambient.
So we need the FSD equivalent for
robotics, right? Data collection needs
to stay out of loop, fade into the
background so we can capture the full
glory of human dexterity across all
walks of life and all areas of economic
value.
So we are going all in into human
egocentric videos. Here's a sample from
our training set. We have these detailed
annotations of human hand poses and
language commands.
And in this way, we take the robot out
of the loop. We're able to hit 24 hours
per day and we can scale it up
massively.
So introducing ego scale, 99.9% of the
training data into this model is on
human videos. The model learns to map
directly from camera RGB pixels to 22
degrees of freedom human hands like
dextrous hands that are very similar to
human hands. And what you see here is
fully autonomous.
So eoscale is pre-trained on 20k hours
of human data and there's no robot data
whatsoever in the pre-training and we
predict the human hand pose and language
poses.
And in the next step, action
fine-tuning. We use these so-called data
wearables and on the left is motion
capture gloves and on the right are
customdesigned
uh exoskeleton devices that can give you
precise joint readings.
So in this way we collect 50 hours of
high precision motion capture data and
only four hours of teley operation and
that is less than 0.1% of the teleyop
data in the mix.
And with this ego scale is able to
generalize to these highly dextrous
tasks like sorting a poker card or
manipulating the syringes using only a
few demonstrations.
And perhaps the most fascinating finding
from eoscale is a neuroscaling law. We
discover this relationship between the
amount of data and the optimal loss. And
we can put it in a very clean loar
mathematical equation six years after
the original LOM scaling law.
And if we put these different data
strategies on this map, we have teley
operation data variables and human
egocentric videos two orders of
magnitude apart from each other. And
then everything to the left of this line
does not require a robot in the loop. So
we call this new paradigm sensorized
human data. It's much more scalable than
teleyop and it can get us closer to this
autonomous driving equivalent of the
physical data flywheel.
And that's not the end of the data
strategy. There is actually a second
ring on this figure. And what is that?
The frontier LM companies are now
investing lots and lots of their budget
into acquiring millions of coding
environments and in those environments
they do reinforcement learning. So same
for robotics, we need to start
collecting environments.
Of course, you can do reinforcement
learning in the real world, but that
gets expensive very, very fast. So
instead, you can take an iPhone video
and then pass it through a 3D world scan
pipeline to extract all the objects and
then reconstruct them in ISAC lab
simulation.
So here, all the objects you see are
fully interactive.
And then we're turning your iPhone into
a pocket world scanner that can port the
physical world into the digital world at
scale.
And once you're in is lab, you can
generate endless variations that we call
digital cousins.
So still this pipeline would require a
classical graphics engine. Can we do
better? introducing group dreams and
that is our spin on video world models
and turn them into full-fledged neuro
simulators. Groot dreams take as input
the motor actions and then outputs the
next RGB frame and sensor states.
So everything you see here is generated.
No pixels is real.
And good dreams learn the different
mechanics of the robots through data
alone.
There's no handgineered physics
equations or anything here. Fully
generated.
So to sum up, this is a new post-
training paradigm where you do
reinforcement learning on a few real
robust stations and then world scans on
graphics cores and finally neural world
models like Cosmos on heavy inference
compute. And as a wise man would say,
compute equals environment equals data.
or the more you buy, the more you save.
And this message has been approved by my
boss.
And we can wrap all of these
environments in Python sandboxes because
we realize that simulation and the real
robot stack at the end of the day are
just code. So you can connect them to
coding agents by passing in multimodal
observations and then turning the
modules like pointing segmentation
depths estimation and motion planning
into agentic tools.
And once you have these tools, we can
let the robot discover skills by
exploring, debugging, and collecting new
insights in these sandboxes. This is a
work fresh out of the oven called Aspire
that gives the robots an ever
compounding everexpanding skill library.
So it enables a new type of continual
learning that transfer skills across sim
and real.
And next we can scale up and compute
equals tokens equals skills in this new
paradigm.
And next we can scale this up from a
single robot to a whole fleet of robots.
This is a time lapse that we captured at
a lab. It's kind of like night at a
museum. You know, the robot fleet comes
alive. They talk to each other in code,
practice novel skills. Um, and they even
go online and read papers, have a
debate, reflect, debug, get stuck, try
different things, and then try again
directly on the hardware. And over time,
they're able to learn a lot just by this
autonomous self-driving process.
How it works is we give the robot fleet
codeex agents and then we give them a
simple goal that is to solve the task as
quickly as possible given a very
generous token budget. And here you see
that every robot station is trying out a
different research idea.
It is a continuous loop that goes from
autoreset auto eval to auto policy
improvement. And we observe that this
fleet of agents can collectively hail
climb a task from 0% to almost 100%
success rate. And it is our earliest
attempt at physical auto research. So
our long-term goal is that all of our
team can take a holiday and Jensen
wouldn't even notice.
So to summarize,
we started with a foundation
intelligence for robotics and we can add
an agentic orchestrator on top. So that
at the end of the day, the total robot
capability equals foundation
intelligence plus robot plus agentic
intelligence. The foundation sets it
floor and the agentic side of things
raises the ceiling.
And that concludes our tour of the great
parallel to the frontier.
And the best thing is you can build this
with us. We're taking all of you along
the journey. So NVIDIA and hugging face
are continuing to expand our
collaborations.
We're developing ISAC teleyop and then a
group models and our physical AI data
sets on hugging face. And I'm very happy
to announce that recently we hit 10
million downloads of our models of our
code and physical AI data sets.
And launching today is a new Nvidia ISA
group end to end workflow. It is a fully
validated open platform that puts
together all the different stages in the
life cycle of developing advanced robot
autonomy. you know from data collection
to training right from curation to
deployment on the Justin source and then
all protected by Nvidia Halo's safety
framework and this platform is modular
and extensible you can take some or all
of it from the menu and a lot of our
humanoid partners are already adopting
this end to end workflow
and of course we are working beyond
uh just the humanoid robots
We're carrying the physical AI ecosystem
on our back.
So what's next? What excites me the
most? I would say my definition of
solving robotics is to pass the physical
touring test where across a wide range
of tasks you cannot tell the difference
between whether a human or robot had
done the task. Right? physical touring
test is deceptively simple but very very
difficult and it's going to be the next
grand challenge for AI and judging by
how sexy the robot went out here I think
we got work cut out for us now the next
question is when can we solve it when
can we get to the end of the endgame
it took the AI community 14 years to go
from the first forward pass of AlexNet
to Fable 5 that we have today and let's
add another 14 years and that will be
and technology compounds exponentially.
It's very hard as humans to grasp the
exponential curve because looking back
it seems flat but looking forward it
looks vertical.
And I'm 90% certain that by 2040 we'll
get to the end of the endgame.
The physical AI revolution will not come
all at once. It will happen gradually
and then suddenly. And as as a wise man
would say, if you believe in robotics,
robotics will also believe in you.
Thanks everyone.